(intriguing music)
- [Narrator] Yabusame is an ancient ritual
that practices samurai-style
archery on horseback.
And for 850 years, one family
has been keeping this tradition alive
with one of the oldest
samurai schools in the world.
(delicate music)
By day, Kiyomoto Ogosawara is a doctor
working to find a cure for cancer.
But by night, he's a samurai instructor,
a job that has been in his
family for generations.
(foreign language)
The school teaches the manners
and fundamentals of how samurais moved.
Students learn how samurai stood,
how they used the bow,
and how they walked.
But the most impressive
thing the school teaches
is a ritual that was at the center
of what it meant to be a true samurai:
drawing a bow and mounting a horse.
(foreign language)
There is a yearly festival
for the best archers to
showcase their skills.
The course is about 240 meters long,
and some wear classical hunting attire
while shooting at fixed
targets on horseback.
It's a way to help
showcase an important part
of their culture, one they
hope is never forgotten.
(foreign language)